l'audit a à valider 12 séquences qui
avaient contourné la la chaîne de de
production
habituelle des demandes pour arriver à
l'antenne effectuées par rachidienne par
qui est toujours à l'oral modification
ou ajout sans validation de rédacteur en
chef dans un délai toujours très tardif
très proche du journal les contusions de
l'audit ont donc montré craché il a une
partie avait sciemment contourné les
processus internes
il m'a donné le nom de Jean-Pierre
Duthion en me disant immédiatement que
Jean-Pierre Duthion lui avait proposé un
certain nombre d'informations et que il
était de son libre arbitre
journalistique de les prendre ou pas et
immédiatement il a nié une contrepartie
financière dans la mesure où il avait
jugé que ces informations devaient être
dans son journal qu'elle avait été le
processus qu'il avait suivi pour refaire
valider cette information là il a été
plus qu'évasif puisque il m'a dit que la
rédactrice en chef n'avait pas été au
courant la ligne éditoriale et
l'intégralité des journaux sont validés
intégralement par un rédacteur en chef
en amont donc il y a un rédacteur en
chef un chef d'édition qui avant la mise
en scène des journaux valide l'ensemble
des séquences évidemment comme Rachid
mbarky a pu vous le raconter hier le
journaliste est libre de ces textes il a
la compétence
il a la liberté éditoriale en revanche
le contenu du journal est intégralement
validé par par le rédacteur en chef et
ce serait donc pour vous qu'il a aussi
volontairement de manière organisé donc
choisi ces moments où il pouvait
diffuser c'est reportages oui c'était
pas des moments où il y a personne
puisqu'il y a toujours quelqu'un mais
les rédacteurs en chef sont sur
plusieurs tranches donc toujours quand
le rédacteur en chef était occupé à
autre chose pendant ce moment-là est
toujours en dernière minute et souvent
avec des chefs d'édition par exemple qui
était pas des titulaires et qui Rachid
embarquis est un grand professionnel qui
est à l'antenne de BFM depuis ses débuts
donc il y a une forme de crédibilité par
rapport à des jeunes rédacteurs chefs
d'édition qui était là ce soir là et
quand il leur demande de faire ça
ils le font ça je voulais avoir votre
avis sur la procédure qui est menée par
BFM TV sur l'identification des sources
des images qui sont diffusés à votre
antenne quand ces images ne viennent pas
de la rédaction de BFM TV ou ne viennent
pas d'une banque d'image les images qui
vont à l'antenne de BFM TV nous avons
une cellule documentation une cellule ce
qu'on appelle news corde et donc
l'ensemble des images qui vont à
l'antenne de TV sans aucune exception
sont toutes certifiées donc une image
n'arrive à l'antenne de façon fortuite
et sans savoir d'où elles viennent et
quand nous avons des doutes par exemple
ça s'est passé sur la guerre en Ukraine
ou il y a eu des mises en scène
organisées dans le cadre de de la
riposte
ukrainienne il nous arrive de diffuser
des images comme celle-là pour lequel
nous avons des doutes sur la véracité du
moment mais nous l'expliquons parce que
c'est un sens journalistique mais en
l'occurrence là elles ont été ingérées à
l'antenne par des images que Rachid
mbarkin n'a pas à reconnu avoir été
donné par Jean-Pierre Dutu est-ce qu'à
votre connaissance qu'on révéler les
enquêtes internes est-ce que d'autres
journalistes ont pu être approchés
contactés d'une manière ou d'une autre
par Monsieur duthiro aucune information
n'a été donnée à l'antenne par son
intermédiaire mais oui monsieur Duthion
une fois que Rachid lemarky a été écarté
de l'antenne à contacter d'autres
journalistes de BFM TV pour leur
proposer d'autres types entre guillemets
d'informations qui n'ont pas suscité
leur intérêt ça vaut pour un de ces
journalistes qu'il a révélé dans le
cadre de l'enquête interne lui a été
proposé à ce moment-là une rétribution